This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Do your mom's house.
Christina,
please go ahead.
Knows how to Hughes
see takes shape.
No Splenda too soon.
Huh?
She takes shit.
It's
Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam.
This is a sloppy state
troopers by Frankie.
It's not ironic is that you always make
fun of my state troopers and it's always
floating in the ethers.
Milkers doin today.
Oh my God. They're so fucking
enormous and I'm so heavy.
I've five and a half more weeks left in
this pregnancy and I am ready to be done
with it. Yeah. Heavy, heavy.
Where are you going to be gene?
Oh Shit. Okay. We're going there
already. Huh? It's how we do it.
Welcome to the show.
I only have two dates left in this
year of 2018 a Jew door titties.
December 8th I'm doing
the Grammercy theater.
There's literally a handful of tickets
left. You better scoop those up now.
And I know it sounds like a long time in
advance, but that's how we roll dudes.
And November 24th in Man
Diego at the House of Blues.
Same Story. Just a few tickets left.
So that's also Thanksgiving weekend.
So if you're looking for something to
do to get away from your awful family,
or even if you like them and you want
to get away from them and you're in San
Diego, come see me at the House of
Blues tickets at Christina P on line.
Thank you.
That is what I've got a
couple new shows doing a nose.
Oh,
Yay.
New shows. You mean Jutia
Jews shows. Here we go. Go.
I'm coming to, well, months, the Wellmark
theater in Montclair, New Jersey. Oh,
uh, November 15th. The tickets go on.
Presale on Wednesday,
June 13th,
10:00 AM the code word is champ,
c h a m p bullshit.
And then the general
on sale begins Friday.
That happens, yes. This week.
So also adding a show in
Orlando at the hard cock live.
Um, nine 30, the late show.
The first show is nearly sold out. That's
November 3rd. So if you're in Orlando,
Florida, you didn't get tickets
to the first time around.
I'm coming for a second show, November
3rd at the hard rock live. Uh,
and by the way, next week I will
also announce another new show. Um,
where else am I going to be hard? Uh,
chose her now on sale in Fort Myers,
Florida on sale in Augusta,
Georgia.
West Palm, Florida is on sale.
Brass balls. What else has tickets?
There's some tickets left in a, well,
there was a second show added in Boise.
Eugene's almost done. Uh, ball Sacramento.
Fresno, Bakersfield. Okay.
When are you doing all this?
This is the end of the year.
Yeah. October, November, all
that times the great outcome.
Your tickets. Tickets. Yeah.
Tick get pit tickets. Your tickets, gene.
Um,
that's it.
Thank you both of our sponsors and welcome
to this episode of Your Mom's house.
That's one of the great podcast.
If you're looking for enlightenment,
this is where academics and some of
the world's leading scientists or
downloading at this very moment with
you to find out what's going on in the
world of astronomy and medicine.
We're very,
we're socially active as well.
Politics.
We talk a lot about that on the show too.
Absolutely.
And drops and current events. We got
him. These are my favorite topic.
I go retarded. So I'm home. I'm
home here and now what does he say,
man, I'm a home. I'm home. You know,
people are are saying yelling at me,
I guess obviously that he's
saying homie. Oh, mine out.
Homie. On out. Homie. On out.
Yeah. Yeah. Whoa man. Out.
Okay. No, I back in the home.
He home. Ya Know How homeless?
Yeah, no shit. Am I be home?
This is like the Lord gave me a home,
Ya know? Yeah. Fuck. How am I mean?
I still think it's home. I'm home here
now. I mean, can we contact this person?
Yeah. He's really, I'm sure
super excited about this.
Very excited. He doesn't know
what's happening. He doesn't know.
Let's get into this show is so much to do.
There's a lot to talk about. All right,
here we go. Oh wait. Oh Man. Yeah.
For some reason this didn't
go over [inaudible] morning
everyone. I don't know.
It sounds good already.
Uh,
dad mouth slit. I doesn't matter.
This smells you can tell. I think so.
Yeah. It smells like horror
garbage like fiefs mouth.
Okay. All right. I don't know why that
went that way, but Homey, man, oh man.
Out of his mouth. Looks
like it stinks. Poor guy.
I know. It's not his fault. Maybe he's
going to say something real sweet.
You're going feel bad. I doubt
that. I highly doubt that.
Good morning everyone.
I'm on the job side getting ready to
start my day and I couldn't be happier
about it.
But what I'd really rather be
doing is coming to your home.
Yeah.
Coleman,
your grandmother's hair.
So where are his top teeth? I Dunno.
And I also noticed that there weren't
so many molars on the side bottom.
It seemed like it was just kind of
see now how did I know? Just
based on the, the small,
narrow row of bottom teeth I saw,
I was like, this guy doesn't have,
I don't know if like over
here and over here, nothing
there. It's blank. Two, three,
four, five. You don't need a lot
more than five. I know that much.
Those are actually the most useless
teeth. The ones in the front, bottom row,
you don't need those for shit.
It's the Maulers you really need.
And those are the ones that fall out
the most. I feel he's right here though,
are the scariest dead. This
look nice guy. He's like,
I'm going to comb your grandmother's hair.
Fuck.
This might be a whole new lane of,
and by the way, this is also a guy,
this is who I see as being like,
Hi Christina. Good morning. Yeah.
And then like a door shuts and he's like,
do you comb your hair yet?
And you're like, mmm. Yeah, he's scary.
Is coming to your home.
Coleman,
your grandmother's hair
kind of like this a lot too.
Well I do. You know why?
Because I know what's about to happen.
We're about to have another
breakthrough in your mom's house videos.
This is going to be a whole new lane for
us. It's a lot of pressure on the video.
I feel it though.
I,
my spidey senses are tango is going
for people that go that's coming either
don't know. I mean 98%
of the time, you know,
we are seeing this with you. It's not
like this is prepared. And I go, oh,
I know it's wrong. Let me tell
you why I think this is good. Uh,
the backgrounds terrible again,
he's in a class is wearing a shirt,
which is not protocol.
You know,
as we think that he's
a little too sensible.
He's got something weird to tell us
cause he's in a private and closure.
Isn't the car adding up?
Let's see.
You know, she needs it calm. You
know what's going to make her happy?
It makes me happy to do it.
Why don't you look Mike come to your
home and comb that hair out of your
grandmother's face.
What's happening?
I don't know,
but I was just expecting
like the next part he's like,
and then I'll her fucking
skull or common rise.
I wasn't going there with it but I was
going there. That's what he wants it.
He wants to come in your grandma's hair.
He wants to mash it down.
Like give him,
give her a good boy here.
He brushes it to the side parts,
it all might come there.
Skidway
that's what he really wants to do.
So it's so scary.
You know what's even scarier?
Imagine if this guy is actually, oh, we'll
say just a really nice guy. He's like,
Hey, was that a funny video?
I'm, I was scared to death.
I was just terrified.
Like his son was like,
make a viral video. He's like, hey man,
it's one about combing your
grandmother's hair. I was like, no.
Did read really wrong.
Read real scary.
He has to know he's creepy.
How about the dog?
Oh Shit.
What'd you let me come to
your home and pet the dog? No.
You know the dog needs it. It makes
him happy. I'm happy to pick the dog.
It's a win win situation.
Let me come to your home and pet that dog.
How is there not more to this? What
do you mean? That's it. That's it. No,
that can't be the whole video.
That's what I was sent blue band.
We need more information.
This can't be everything.
Um,
yeah.
Says he's living for Pizza Hut.
Huh?
I Dunno what, how was it? The whole video?
It doesn't feel like it's the whole video.
There's something nefarious going on here.
Come on.
Blue Band and he wants
to come in your dogs.
No,
she needs you to call home
blue band. Send me the rest
of this fucking video. Yeah.
This is not the whole story. Some
something's going on. Oh my God.
This baby's moving so fast. This kid
does somersaults and me all fucking day.
He's going to come out while gene.
You better brace yourself.
Oh my God, Dude. Oo Dancing on my bladder.
Anyways, um, I did my Netflix
shoot this last week. Great.
Uh, Las Vegas. What's well,
it's Las Vegas and our language.
A lost anus. Anus. I want to thank
everybody that came out to the taping.
Joey Diaz and I were on
the same night with Yama.
Nika and I gotta tell
you it was fucking chaos.
I think it was crazy. That was pretty
wild for people that it was crazy.
We're not at that show.
It was in downtown Las Vegas,
right on Fremont Street and a bar there.
Normally a musical venue.
It was called like backstage billiard,
so it was a proper rock venue,
but they built a special set for the
stage and then you have an eco went up the
gray than you are in the
wings ready to go now. Okay.
So I'm getting ready. I'm
fucking seven months. What?
Almost eight months pregnant.
Yeah.
And I'm standing backstage
and there's a music cue,
some rock song like Jeez, a cowgirl one.
Know Dan. I'm like, yeah, I don't know.
And then can picture too,
you know,
obviously there's a couple of hundred
people there. Yeah. Um, full, you know,
obviously crew for a production backstage.
It's like all the producers and all the
executives and there's video village.
It's just, it's very busy.
There's a lot going on.
There's a smoke machine rolling
the smoke, smoke, smoke, smoke,
smoke and there's smoke.
And then I'm standing right
there and I'm waiting for my cue to go
out on the stage to do the first show.
My first set ever of this taping,
right.
The smoke is going and I noticed that
the production person is having trouble
opening the door to the stage.
And like Fifo,
I watch our dogs and the brilliance
of Fifo, not so much bitsy. Uh,
but fif is that when he sends his danger,
you know what that dog does?
He gets the fuck out of the way.
Yeah. You see his spidey sense?
Yeah. Eyebrows actually ray. Yeah. Yes.
No, and I, I swear to you, and
I'm not saying this as a bit,
I did think of Fifo at that
moment and I was like, oh,
I think I should get out of the way.
Some tells me something bad is
about to happen. I swear to God.
And I moved away cause I was like,
this is dangerous. And Lo and behold,
a heavy fucking, I don't
know, seven foot door door,
what?
Indoor and this poor production lady,
she's opening it and it
falls like just centimeters,
millimeters from my hand and it falls
down and crashes down right where I was
just standing.
And of course everybody's freaking out
and they have to Redo it and reset it.
And I'm,
we're all in the back waiting to go up.
So that was what happened right before
I went up. And what I thought to myself,
this is really good luck because
when I had my first special taping,
remember that guy that took a shit during
my shell and then he kept flushing the
toilets over and over in Seattle and
I had to stop my set and be like,
is somebody going to
address the toilet flushing?
Yes guys taking a shit during my,
somebody was shitting in the middle
of my show and fucking up sound.
So I feel as though it's a good omen
when something like that happens and the
first tape, the first taping
went and was good. It was great.
The second one was even better and we got,
we got what we needed so it's
going to be a great show.
I hope you guys enjoy it and
thank you again for coming.
So we had a good time in Vegas.
New Gene. The A, the second show was
was killer. That was the jam. Yeah.
Thank God for a second. Shit. God,
they tape two shows every show.
I feel like every time I take something,
a specialist they shower. Yeah, for sure.
And you ended up, you always
end up, it's funny cause you go,
it's all about the second show.
You always end up using something
from the first show. Yeah.
You don't remember at the time,
but when you watch the cut you're like,
oh actually that was how I like it more.
Yeah. But the usually, I don't know,
like the vibe
energy's always better on the
second show because you shake the,
shake the nerves off from the first
show and then by the second one you're
relaxed. The audience, it's a little bit
later in the evening, other little loose,
but a man that was like, I got to
tell you, I don't, I'm not a huge,
we're not a huge Vegas couple. It's
not really our jam. Speak for yourself.
Um, but being in that downtown
location was just quiet.
I forgot.
Like I forgot.
Brought back the memories of our,
when we lived in Korea town,
downtown adjacent here. You mean the
rampart? Yeah, the Rampart Division.
Macarthur Park. Um, you
see a lot of kicky footers.
Kicky photos.
It's a,
somebody is in a wheelchair,
um,
but they have the use of their legs and
the way that they move the chair around
as they kicked her big
kick, kick, kick your foot,
they push and then they back up.
And sometimes they go forward
with their feeds and you go, oh,
you just feel like sitting. And
they're like, yeah, yeah. It's kind of,
it's not fair to the people that might
really need the wheelchair. Sure.
It has a ceiling. I remember
there was a kicky foot lady, uh,
down on sixth street there.
She rolled hood. Yeah.
And I saw a guy, the bearded
lady wasn't at the bearded one.
No, the bearded guy. There's a bearded
man with paint his beard on. Yeah,
I remember that guy. Yeah. But there was
this one lady that I used to always see,
but uh, downtown Vegas had a
guy cookie fighting. Right.
Cause several, a whole team of KCI
flutters. It felt like a whole,
a whole situation. And
you know, it's just,
it's not my bag downtown Vegas.
And
so we, we stayed in, uh,
uh, the, the, the morgue.
That whole section seems like it's a,
just a parole hearing
gathering. So there's, are
there court courthouses there?
There should be. I mean, yeah, there
are, but yeah, it just, Oh my God,
the Greyhound station is right there.
It is a great hand stitch the whole thing.
Yeah. That's what it is. Yeah.
But it was nice to kind of reminisce
because the early stages of our careers,
we did a lot of shows down there. Oh
yeah. Yeah. We used to do four queens.
I knew that.
Yeah. And I did the Golden Nugget and
uh, you know, these Vegas Palace station,
a station or liens.
I did the sands before it was gone.
I did the Riv before it was
going on in Harrah's was arrows.
That's where the Improv is. Yeah. The
trop I did that. I just do all of them.
And people will know when you do,
you know, you do the road, you're,
you're typically on most club. Weekends
are Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
and sometimes Sunday. Vegas you do
Monday through Sunday, brewed all.
So you arrive Monday and you do
one show a night until Saturday.
You two shows Saturday.
And uh,
I really thank God that I don't
have the gambling gene. Okay.
We don't have the fun gene. Let's back
it up. You and I, out of all the agents,
the managers,
the executives to other comedians on this
thing are probably the most antisocial
people. Yeah. Like we should be
fun and we're the least fun. Yeah.
I always get that.
We have no fun
ruin the wonderful, one of the
calls I got one time was a, Hey,
do you want to do just one of these
festivals? You know, I would been like,
Moon Tower or oh, you're one of
these festivals. And I go, well,
what's the like, what's the deal? And they
were like, well, it's not a great offer,
but it's like a great hang. Now
go, excuse me. And he's like, well,
you know, like all your friends
will be there. And I was like,
I don't care what my friends are here in
la. Yeah. And they're like, well yeah,
to just be with them in another
city and no. Yeah. You party. I go,
I don't fucking party. And
they're like, hey man, you
don't want to do it again. No,
I don't want to do it.
I want to do like a regular shirt.
I don't care if it's a
festival was involved. Yeah.
Well cause we can go down to the comedy
store and see those exact same people.
Then my festivals on sunset,
it's, it's easy. Yeah.
I don't need to fly to on Thursday
night festival or much Montreal.
Yeah. To fly across the world. No, I
know none of those things. They're like,
you're going to hang a no,
no. Go to bed by 10 yeah.
And that's what we did after the taping.
They were like,
we're going to go out now. We're like,
no, I'm exhausted. He is exhausted.
It's crazy to say to you, I
mean, you're fucking super price.
People still are like, you want to go
out? I'm like, no, I want him to lay down.
You're going out, right? No, no. Yeah.
You're going to leave your pregnant
wife nor the phones. Hell Oh my God.
I had two crazy,
crazy phone things into weeks in
hotels in Vegas where we get back,
we ordered too much food as
usual. We wind down our fun. Yeah.
That was our celebration.
Ordering too much Chinese dumplings
about whatever the fuck to go to bed.
So we're like, all right. You
know, congratulations. Big Win,
you know, great special.
Finally she goes to bed. I go,
I'm going to go to bed too.
I'm talking because I flew the
day before back from Charlotte.
Then the next day to Vegas,
I'm tired.
We laid down and was
like on cue the phone,
which is sitting on the nightstand
have this nice hotel goes dial tone.
The speakerphone goes on.
So you're like,
what's that? And you just kind of hit
it off like, okay. That was weird.
A minute later. Uh, so
then I'm like, well,
what's happened with this phone?
I just tried to like fix
it every 45 seconds or so.
It keeps going on. Did I try to unplug it?
It's like sealed. Yeah. Into the phone.
Yeah. Then I called down, hey,
how did you call down though?
I just called. I called
guest services from another,
from the other thing. Cause there
were two phones. Yeah. How did you,
I guess you picked the other line or
something like that. I don't know.
I was like, oh my God, I so tired
too because I had fallen asleep.
It wasn't right away, you know, both in
a dead sleep. I got up to Paris, right,
came back and then it started doing it.
Then I start telling them, I'm like,
here's what's happening with the phone.
They're like, okay, we'll try to get some.
I go, no, no, no, no. I was like,
you have to send somebody now.
I'm going crazy right now and
as I'm doing that I hear like,
I don't like, I hear shit like
crashing, like what the fuck?
And you had met, I mean I'm
telling you at my full strength,
like you know, I mean I didn't try
to violently do it, but I was like,
oh this is not like a regular plugin
like this. You know what I mean?
Like it's not, it wasn't like a
regular, not a regular phone line.
It was like actually like, I don't
know. Sealed in there somehow.
Christina manage from the bed, seven and
a half months pregnant. She just go Bam.
And like the phone went flying off
and I go, ah, yeah, just send them up.
So then I take what you did,
kind of piece it back together.
And when the guy gets there and set
up being like, fix it, I go, yeah,
well I'm telling you,
Hell hath no fury like a pregnant woman
trying to get her two hours of sleep.
And that whole ordeal, by the way,
was that was like a 25 minute ordeal.
Of course it kept going up and the rage
inside of me, I was like, dude, I fucking,
I am exhausted.
I yanked it as hard as I have no idea
what could make a fucking phone do that.
I don't know.
Do,
I mean literally it's dial tone would
just come through the speaker like every
minute. But I, at that point
I didn't care. I was like,
I'm going to pay for this phone. I'll
give you $200 or whatever it is. I can't,
I can't listen to this shit.
But the best part is, um,
as you call down for, for
room service, remember?
And what did you say? Oh I ordered and
then she was like, cause I go, yeah,
she goes, okay, we'll be up in
like 30 minutes ago. Thanks.
Gambling jeans. And she,
I thought she had already
hired when she goes
like all her gambling jeans.
Yeah.
Well Cause I've been calling people
mommy and jeans like just openly and
rampantly. Zero pushback. No,
and I mean I'm calling technology
sometimes car just to be like,
why'd you call me Mommy? I'm like,
I'm just calling your mommy. You know,
I spent $40 by the way, on the slots.
I was walking through the slots.
He did just lots.
Yeah.
And I went up to 65 and I was like did
when I went down there and then I took
that money, I put it in another
machine. We had lost it in like 5 cents.
I'm, you know, I don't really
understand the thrill of gambling.
It's just not get it.
But I don't have the like it's
either excites you or it doesn't.
It terrifies me because I know how,
how hard it is to earn money.
I feel like it's the eastern block or in
me is like, no dude, I'm not doing this.
My friend, my money down the toilet,
Claudia is asking this question.
I've got to tell her
our nanny dose.
So,
um,
somebody wanted to send you this.
Really check this out.
They have a little clap
back. Oh Shit. Here we go.
It's not that bad. Here we go
there. She said, how dare you.
I don't want to read. You can go ahead
forward. Hey Mommy, not reading it.
Brendan and Taylor here.
Just want to point out that me tailor the
female bought the shirt the first time
it was mentioned. Also must mentioned
I bought Brendan's Rub, Rub,
rub shirt as well. All my idea.
Female idea. So take it doctor drew.
Oh Wow. They're getting, they're
getting, they're engaged.
We're getting married very soon.
A congrats. Congratulations.
If you have any marriage advice.
Yeah,
don't marry this chick because she's
obviously got sociopathic tendencies.
Oh, that's your, she wrote
the email though, Babe. Oh,
you guys should then you're perfect
for each other. You both psychos.
If you buy these shirts together,
that's your advice to anyone that gets
a four stroke shirt is a disgusting
animal. No, no, it's, it's the forest
strokes and the rep both. Both.
She bought both. Yeah. Well,
you guys are clearly mentally disturbed
and you're perfect for each other and
the work is done. There you
go. Um, what dose do you have?
Two people married getting married.
I think they already have. I mean,
they look happy. Um, they have
obviously a shared sensibility.
What does it keep making each other laugh?
You gotta don't take yourself
too seriously. Give each
other haircuts, haircuts.
Um,
always you as the man always should cut
her hair and style and color her hair.
Um, you should do her makeup. You should
do her eyebrows. Um, you know, you should,
uh, don't take her for
granted. That's good.
Don't take each other for
granted, I would say. Right.
Stay aware.
It's always nice to have gratitude.
So I think it's nice when people say
things like just basic, you know,
thank you's. You know what I mean?
Like you don't just go like, yeah,
of course you fucking made me
eggs. You, you say thank you.
I always try to say thank you.
I think we adore each other.
I think that's number one is to stay,
stay adoring and liking the
stuff you liked, you know,
10 15 years ago and to remember why
you fell in love with that person.
I know what I honestly of the only other
thing I would say is don't go camping
to fuck him. You know what I would say?
Why? Why? Because we hate camping. Well,
here's what I was going to say.
That Mary, somebody where you guys,
you people like always,
what do you have in common then?
No know it's what you
both hate and common.
That's really what's going to unite you
as a couple is both the both of you hate
the same stuff. For instance, Tom
and I, we don't go out late partying.
That's really not our thing. We both hate
camping. Yeah, we both hate concerts.
Both like to stay at home.
We hate loud environments.
Hey crowds,
crowds hate fucking cunt
servers can't servers.
Billy Joel, our mutual hatred.
I don't hate Billy jolt.
I don't know why you're putting it,
don't you?
I don't know why you put that on me.
Bruce Springsteen. I don't like him.
We both hate Dylan. Bob Dylan,
he's garbage. Trash, trash.
Frank Sinatra hate him.
You're really more United by the shit
you hate when you're a couple. It's true.
Um, I think things like
that too. You know,
Matt Dillon, when he was
like, he's a treasure. I know.
You expect to get the music. It's
funny because you really, people,
some people treat them music. The music
they love. Like it's family. Right.
You know, especially if they've been
listening for 15, 20, 30 years. It's like,
it's like saying, Hey, your dad's sucks
basically. Yeah. You know? But yeah,
you can't expect everyone.
I'd like to see course.
I think it's funny when
someone really gets the sounds,
they like to hear you having different
sounds. You like to hear it. Yeah,
my sounds are the best. And
you're like, okay, good teams.
I don't want to hear fucking,
oh my God.
The other one I love about sports is when,
when people attack a professional as a,
they suck.
Like there'll be like Lebron James
Sucks. And you're like, that's cool.
Like he sucks. Like, yeah.
Like he's okay. I mean,
we're talking about, you know, objectively
physical freaks of all, you can't,
you can't accept that. Fuck him.
He sucks. He's no good. Okay. Oh,
you know what I would suggest for married
people who are newly cohabitating or
who have been living together for years
by a cleaning lady, get a cleaning lady.
I think that alumni, a cleaning
lady, have a slave in your pantry,
but you said the word wrong,
but get a cleaning lady.
You got 40 bucks to spare.
Have someone else clean your home.
We did it when we were the brokest.
I think it was once a month
when you're like, all right,
this is what it was like a
little apartment and I think
someone would do it for
like 50 bucks.
It's the best $50 we ever
stab because when they are
done you're like, oh yeah, I,
I, I'll, I'll never keep it
like this. Yeah. So I think
about having a clean close,
here's what it does. It a alleviates the
fights between the two of you do too.
Who Cleans what in the house,
right. Preach, preach, preach.
I don't yell at you about your boxer
shorts on the floor or the song, you know,
yell at me for my sloppiness
because someone else fucking pigs.
Plus there's gross shit that you
don't want to do. Hey, you know,
stains on toilets and on a sinks
that are just, you know what I mean?
Like just from being Greg toothpaste
and shit builds and it's like,
and then you have to fight over who does
the toilets and who, and not only that,
you work 40 hours a week.
Most Americans work a full fucking weak.
Why are you spending
your weekends scrubbing
your toilet unless it's something you
really enjoy and all a lot of people love
to clean or you have to do.
Yeah,
but I'm saying if you have 40 by hammered
how much ever it is in your region.
Yeah.
Save your money.
I would rather that's really have the
cleaning lady then go out for fucking
dinner that month. Do you know what
I'm saying? It's, it's way more.
Uh, I dunno. I think it's a
huge life saver. Personally.
I think just to spite you.
Apparently the mommies have
taken over the romance,
the Rogan comment section
are those videos yet.
And it is like all rob rubs says like
thick,
hot, white come. My brother didn't
believe me so hard. I'm hearing it.
What's up with this one
here? No. People are like,
are these all bots that are responding
to it? Try it out right now. Right now.
Right now. Uh, Peyton Lafferty
take 10 or 12 Benadryl.
I don't think this is despite me is
I'm just, no, I'm just kidding. Oh,
whole man out. Whoa,
man. This is hilarious.
So it's very funny.
You cannot fuck with the mommies.
And there's another, you cannot,
a lady who mentioned this said,
uh,
hey,
mommy's first one to say the doctor drew
podcasts are by far my favorites. Yes.
His reactions are the best, by the
way. I'm going to do his podcast.
Great. The which one Hashtag
[inaudible] you live.
He needs to change the title of that.
I Dunno.
He's like life Hashtag
you live at Dr drew.
Like I gotta talk to him about this.
Um, I'm not sure it was called
I'm doing it Thursday. Uh,
I wanted to write in about Dr Drew's
saying there is always a man behind the
woman. We get emails about this
and that. It's not always the case.
I actually submitted a try it out video
on my own fruition the day after Tom put
his on Instagram because I was so excited,
but I'm not sure I sent it correctly.
Uh, it was actually me trying to
get my friends to do it with me,
not the other way around.
I actually find myself
intentionally slipping in the words,
try it out in conversation, know, so I
can chuckle to myself. I love what you do.
Your podcast giving me laughs
even in the darkest moments,
always keeping it high
and tight. Sophia, Sophia,
point out that I pushed back
on drew when he said that,
and I said that not our listeners.
I believe that the women that listen
to this show are self starters,
self initiators. When it came to funding
and creating these wacky videos. Listen,
if you're a girl and you're listening
to this show, yeah, you're already,
you're fucking thousand times cooler
than most checks. Yeah. And your,
your fucking head isn't on right. You
know what I'm saying? Like your flux,
just like I am. I'm, you know
the main mommy say that guys.
Who the fucking fuck? Uh, my gosh,
she's a sexual life. Fuck me.
Then you can move in, but you have
to fuck me and I, I need a lot man.
Pretty hot here, man.
She's too attractive.
It's almost serious power plug. I'd
be like, I gotta get this content.
No,
no sir.
You want to move in? Your friend could
movement. This is how I got porno starts.
I feel like she's, she's so pretty. She's
a model, right? A slate cow. I don't know.
Let's
go for a stroll through the,
where's the blowjob? Sorry.
This is the setup to the scene. Her
makeup looks great to, yeah, fuck me.
Piss on me. Cheese.
Everyone's getting a bone or
try it out. You want to Piss me? Try
it. Fuck yeah. I don't know Sophia.
I Boral guy to lean it. Do
it. I want to deliver it.
I'm a hot white trash come
down. Let's fuck. I'm so around.
I think everyone's like a Briggs. Yeah,
he's a Sophia. I don't know if we,
we got the same goal as the other videos,
but he did a great job.
You did a great job and uh,
uh,
please keep sending those videos
then every time you have that idea,
the four stroke one, are we going to
do it for a stroke guy next? Oh yeah.
Are we gonna do enforce
drugs with no traffic?
Rather he couldn't believe that biggest
dig was, that was my favorite part.
My favorite line is still
the neuropathy and uh,
people are when hashtagging that shit
on Twitter, like, yeah, no, no, no, no.
They're also putting it also,
by the way, it's really funny.
I'll be like,
ah,
I'm going to be a Fort Myers November 1st
at your tickets here and there. Like A,
is there an entrance? Is there a special
entrance? If I have neuropathy issues,
Hashtag I couldn't believe
how his dick was so crazy,
so crazy. He jumped off, drove,
he's so impressive now on
your app. I mean, yeah.
His focus in life is fucking on
hold on. Before we move on. Yeah.
From the marriage topic. Yeah. Uh,
I want to let everybody know that we
were laying in bed last night and I'm
laying in my pregnancy pillow,
so I can't really move a lot.
So when I want affection from you,
I have to demand it like a Brussels
Griffon and come here gimme kisses.
Give me love and you fucking
gave me the laziest air kiss.
Yeah. I have ever seen watching. We were
watching something and you're like, Hey,
give me a kiss.
Yeah.
Instead what I did was I moved my lifts
to the right side of my face because
you're sitting to my right. I mean,
yeah. Even turn your head to the side.
Face, air kiss. I went, yeah, I like
that. Because you are watching a TV show.
I need to even want to turn your
head to look at me to air kiss me.
So you kept your eyes forward on TV
and then you, you side kissed. Yeah,
that's a lazy,
you also snapped me out of it because I
was actually zoned out and whatever we
were watching. So as soon as you pointed
out how bad that was, I did laugh.
Preordained. Yeah. That was the Lazy Shit.
Yeah, it was real lazy. Yeah. I was like,
okay. There you go. No, no
neuropathy. What is this?
I don't know what the hell this is.
This message is for Thomas [inaudible].
This is Justin glassine with the
competitive water consumption consortium.
I just wanted to call to let you know
that we got your results back from our
fair competition,
your analysis department,
and to congratulate you on your latest
victory as the current water champions.
Wow.
Uh,
unfortunately we did find some performance
enhancing salts in your opponent's
sample. Uh, what was her
name? Kristina possessed sky.
Um,
but I can't talk too much about that
right now until the consortium puts out an
official statement concerning that issue.
Whatever.
Before I go,
I just wanted to add that after you
came down here for your analysis,
we cannot stop talking about
how great your presence was.
I swear I haven't been able to walk
into the break room without hearing my
coworkers. Were you telling
your stories or your jokes?
You just have such a great and charismatic
personality and we cannot wait to
have you back in the future.
Um, so it's all I got, you know,
best of luck to you in the future champ.
Well done.
Thanks Justin. That is such
bullshit. You whoa. Who is this guy?
He put them out to this. No, I didn't.
I swear to you that was just
submitted those Justin glassine. Okay.
Justin Glass and it looks like the
city of Fremont is back with an update.
Thank God. Oh my God. Yeah. This
is a little gift and speech.
Actually, I'm a pussy boy. Oh, giving
back now downtown Vegas in the shit hole.
But I can relocate any place because
I get social security, you know,
and we carried,
I don't look my age of 66 huh?
66 I don't look,
my age is 66 86 fuck man.
Like God Damn Star Wars character,
which is I guess what the sound he
was making when it started, wasn't he?
I don't like it.
The Placebo. Maybe that'd be
white. Cause I like white, white,
white, white. And you could be mature
like me or well, you know, not too young.
It's actually, I'm looking at
delivery out with, you know, away.
Maybe we get it.
You like White Lady's done.
Ready for you to fuck me up any way you
want to do it. You wait. [inaudible] yeah.
Oh me anyway, come on. You wake
tramp. She has to be dominant.
You know we get it.
Maybe you want to put me in a closure
all the time and picks me up like a girl.
But then I dunno why he always resorts
to going aggro. He's like dress.
He wants to antagonize them
so that they abused him. Wow.
And then if I bay,
she can ask stuff her panties in my mouth
and duct tape my mouth and I be up to
a chair.
I'm going to paraphrase Dr
drew. Oh, the trauma. Yeah.
Yeah. He's been through a
lot, but he's, he was a free
mind. He was right there, man.
Yeah. I, we should have hung out with
them. The pussy boy. A free month.
That's right. You can go anywhere
though. It's the nice thing. Yeah,
he is mobile still. What do you think
about taking them in so disgusting. Look,
he's shirtless and I don't,
I love when somebody looks like it goes,
I don't look my age 66 that's
usually like women who will be like,
yeah, and I'm, I'm actually
really well put together pretty
well and you're like, uh, I like
how you make that judgment on you.
You're telling me the time they look
exactly their age or worse like this
fucking, it's seldom that somebody
doesn't legit look their age.
People who don't never say it.
In other words,
like the person who like
really looks down and goes,
you wouldn't believe how much younger I
looked at it. They just, they are that,
you know, it's like being like
smart people don't go like,
do you want to know how smart I am?
Like they just don't do,
they don't tell you this guy is 66 Bam.
He looks terrible.
Well yeah this is, I mean, I mean
he's got the smoke detector in the back
so that's good. The camera's facing down.
Hold it down. No shirt. So he checks
your mom's house requirements.
Yes. For a shitty videos.
If you had to white white,
White Lady,
give me hours.
Anyone's going to respond to that.
A real crazy person.
Somebody who is equally as sick as he is.
Nobody,
you know that's fucking out of control.
Did you see this thing that went viral?
This a kid talking shit to
this guy at a mark? Some shit.
Good. It's calming. No.
Okay.
Awesome.
This guy did it.
Voice call cause he's just
being like confronted by this
kid.
Look at the kid though.
He's fucking straight up on
this really weird
kid is like on them
started but it looks like the kid is um,
he said don't talk about
my mom or something. Hmm.
I like him
for him.
See he's putting these, he's
touching the guy. That's
what he thinks is right
now. They're actually, yeah.
Leaning a grown man in a kid or
leaning up against each other.
How do you think that
kid is 12 your ranch?
When I got to know more
about what happened here.
Is that something his mom
really funny video. Tom. Thanks.
What part of this is funny for you?
I didn't think it was funny.
I was just showing you the video.
I can't watch a little kid getting hurt
blue cars.
He was, I called him. Nene
starts to take to start testing.
Man. You're could just keep, cause he
just kept running around here. I said,
you need to tell it's
good to get out of here.
God told him to go and he went
down. Right. Where are you?
Bike ran back up here and started pushing.
Shown
who picked this one? Blue banner
videos today are fucking crazy.
What's happening. Um, I don't see anything
wrong with what the guy did though.
Pushing that kid down on the
ground. Yeah. I don't know, Dude.
Like he was swinging on him. The
kidneys checked you, but you have to,
you have to separate them.
Another adult should have
intervened and separated them.
You don't push a little boy down to the
claim. Is that little quick? He's 12 baby.
Yeah. He needed to be checked. We don't
push a kid on the concrete get crack.
It's just fucking, the kickoff
was was punching. Yeah. Yeah.
But you're bigger than him. Aren't there
rules to that? Yeah. Yeah. It's like,
this is what happened is be like, this is
what happens is that kid needs to know,
see what happens is that kid is going
to learn from this incident that if I go
ahead and just punch someone
when I'm angry, yes they could.
It could end poorly for me.
Right. So you need to be able to,
you know,
assess the situation and either restrain
yourself from punching when you want
to.
Certainly don't think that you can punish
someone bigger than you and not have
repercussions. Yeah. No, I get
it. Look good. It is. I mean,
he did the grab a machete to push
them on car. I mean, first of all,
it's a lawsuit waiting to happen. Yeah.
Fucking push a little kid on the floor.
But you're right.
This is called,
this is male thing where you guys have
to learn how to size someone back.
I defy okay.
Like I did him a favor.
I got to pee. I'm sorry I'm pregnant.
I got to go. Don't fuck that.
He should have fucked that kid. No, I said
fuck that kid. Fuck that kid is right.
Are You going to pee? Yeah. All right,
great. How was your p? Pretty magical.
I'm so fucking hungry
today, ma'am. All right.
It's like I have a person inside of
it is like that can't stop eating.
I got this bullshit.
Listen to uh, is bullshit.
It was the one doctor drew was
here. Oh listen. Or a praying lady.
I take amazing dogs.
I always tell him for me that you have
to harass Burt before you eat yours.
Dude, you have to what? You'd
Harass Bert. Do you call me? Bert?
That's what they're saying. Call
me bird. Oh, let's hear it again.
I don't need to have for me.
Then you have to harass Burt before
you eat yours your ass first.
He said burst her ass
her ass first for me.
Then you have to harass
Burt before you ask for.
You have to eat her ass
Berg. Oh, last first.
He said he knows you saying he's trying
to say first and then said they can't.
You just,
yeah,
you're asking you for enough to harass
Burt before you eat her ass bird.
Burb instead I asked burgers.
We got to send it to him ma'am. Yeah,
it's totally unacceptable. Totally on.
It's all going to go do a show now. You
gotta you gotta show him that clip there.
That's it right there. Listen. Burb
first,
did you have to harass Burt before you
through his first not bird bird burp.
Burp. It's cute. Speaking of ass.
I was getting a mom's size yesterday.
Yeah.
And I was holding in so many
farts like the whole time,
like every times when they give you a
massage and they'll push down like from
your mid back to your
lower back towards like,
they're like they're showing
the fart where to go,
like heres your digestive track.
Well I lay on my side for these,
but I ate Mexican food.
I had like so much food and I was
the whole time I've relaxed, relaxed.
Then I'd feel the FARC come back
and then I'd have to clench, clench,
clench plans and then it waits. It would
wake me up and then it occurred to me,
wouldn't it be great to find him a Zeus
that actually encouraged your farts?
That was like, Oh yeah, right
now you got to let that far down.
Breathe in and push hard. Like with
the, like when the whisper, yeah,
you have to Fart.
Go ahead and give me that.
Yeah,
you got to breathe in and you gotta push
that far down and then they're like,
that's right.
I'm sure there is.
There has to be somebody that's like
the fart. I don't know if I would say,
I'm sure there is. I don't think
that that's necessarily correct.
Pharmacists in La maybe.
I mean if you put out a request,
I'm sure someone who likes bars
will be like, I could massage you,
but I don't know if there's
a FARC massage therapy.
The prerequisite isn't that they have to
like the fart but just that they don't
make you clench your ass.
Cause I feel like,
I feel like it takes away from
the relaxation experience.
If I could just let it rip
without embarrassment horse,
how much better would your massage be?
Yeah, if you could be. If you're like,
oh here comes a fart and they're like,
don't worry about it. Yeah cause I,
well you don't know if you have a,
a real rancid one or if you have,
oh mine are horrible right now because
I feel like I'm close enough to the lady
that we go to all the time. I was this
close yesterday. It'd be like, listen,
I got to rip one and you're cool with it.
She'd probably be cold it to probably
be cold and I didn't want to blast like
you. Of course. Of course. What if we
give pay somebody extra and be like,
here's the extra money.
If you just let me fight the whole time,
they would definitely say yes,
I dare you to do it next time we're
at like a nice lake place. He wasn't.
If I know what happened is I go,
if I ship you a little more they're
going to be like, no, no, no, no. Wait,
let me finish my sentence.
Do you mind tip you a little more?
If I can fart the whole time
my,
they're expecting the hand job offer
and you're like, I just got a far,
I just want to, and then she's like,
she'll probably go, people fart
all the time. I'm like, so do you mind,
cause I do feel like that's
the one hindrance to me.
Fully relaxing and enjoying.
Yeah. If I could just take
out that fart barrier.
If you have to far, far,
I'd be like, no, no, no,
but I need you to waft it to yourself.
No, I can. I like it. I like it.
I don't need the encouragement.
What about this guy you think
he would would let you fart?
Here's your massage.
The baby.
It's a baby chick coming aside and Nixon.
I can't take it.
Do you think
so? I kind of big black Dick.
Okay. And so let me dig back
on one horn. He chrysalis.
Sansa cancer claim. Okay.
Yeah.
He said Chrissy, with
your role. So tight hold,
come ride my pipe tonight.
And while the other things me,
I didn't even buddy
hold on.
Crazy heels on. Probably. Yeah.
He really should show them if
he's going to bother wearing.
I know that's a quite a outfit.
What is that?
It's nothing Tom. Just yeah. My,
my least favorite sexual genre.
Yeah. Is the crossing of Christmas,
the Lord of our birth.
The birth of our Lord and Savior with
sexual or sexualizing Santa's. Yeah.
I never understood that. Okay. Yeah.
I fucked sand our singing
Santa Baby. That songs. Yeah,
like that's the least. It's
just, it's a child thing.
It just so like how can we don't do what
the Easter bunny like fucking eastern
money. Yes. I'm sure
I know. I just really,
I really don't like the Santa here.
Is there one thing? I know you, I
know it puts you in a good mood.
We established this yesterday. Yeah,
I know. It can make you laugh. Yeah.
This is again,
part of a,
if you're wondering what makes somebody
happy through a marriage, it's like, okay,
knowing their sweet spots because
one thing I know about you,
you love music. You know you
love scatting. I love scouting.
How about group scatty?
Okay,
Lina.
That's rough man.
Well especially because it's a group
of Dorky white kids. Yeah, I know guys.
You're doing it better than their,
their, their laser Lee doing it.
They're going to get, well, you
get here taps cause all off rhythm.
They're doing it lazy though. They're not
even doing it. So you're doing it Chris.
You're like,
these kids are terrible at this.
This is terrible.
[inaudible]
no,
not the white girl.
Oh Jesus.
Please let the black kid do it.
I can't hear these fucking white
girls doing this. Let's get to him
please.
Is He doing it a hundred times better?
I think I might like scat cause that kid
did it well let me listen to a little
bit of soul
[inaudible]
it's definitely better
than the other people.
But look at all the kids looking at him
like, Whoa, wow, how can really do it?
How it's done.
This is embarrassing.
He got into it.
Don't you feel like,
like this is something you totally could
have fallen into and like elementary
school, oh maybe elementary school. Like
you can just make sounds with your mouth.
You know what I mean? Like um, you know,
like if you're like
I'm in the choir group,
I do music group at school and then
like the music instructor is like,
we're going to do this thing called scat
and you're like young and you're like,
yeah,
what's that?
Well it's like this jazz thing and then
next thing you know there's a video of
you doing this shit. I mean, it would
not be, uh, at their age. No, no.
You're telling me like I was
six or something? Yeah. Yeah.
I'd say up until sixth grade you could
get sucked into doing stupid. No, no, no.
You think 12 1212 I'd be out.
He's this fucking game.
I think I could've gotten roped in
at 12 that would be the last year.
They can make me do something.
That's embarrassing.
1111 [inaudible].
Who's singing that was, that
one was better. Who's that?
Who's to his right and behind her we
can't see who it is. Wow. That one was,
that was my, that was actually the best
one yet. That was the best one. Yeah.
The first few were like
[inaudible] all together.
[inaudible]
let's see. That was better because
they rehearsed it. Right? This, this,
you know, the scat stuff was in.
It was terrible. What if our sons,
like, I just love to Scat Dad,
come listen to the scout record
and act like I liked this nonsense.
Fucking hambone this asshole.
Fuck.
[inaudible]
see now
the last time we played hambone
we did a kind of an analysis,
like who's less talented?
That guy or the lung infection song guy,
lung infection guy won by a landslide,
he killed it.
Now Pam bone versus scat.
Who's,
who's the lesser talent? Well,
that's a good question. I mean,
I think I hated a ham bone guy more.
Yeah.
But I think now that I've spent
some time in the scat world,
I definitely hate them. Well, here's the
thing, the people in the scat community,
they seem to be very earnest.
Like there's a very earnest love of scat,
but the ham bone guy,
I still feel like he's,
he knows that he's put
one over on the audience.
Like he's so smug with how he does it.
And of course that's what contributes
to why you hate him so much.
I've worked this
ham boning my whole life.
Yeah. It's not as, um,
yeah. The other ones just seem so
innocent compared to him. True, true.
What would you rather watch that group,
scat video or handbook for an hour,
an hour.
You're buying a ticket,
you're driving your parking
of the two without question.
I think I could at least get lost
in the fact that he does movement.
And I know, but they were terrible. Okay.
Would you rather watch an Andrew
Lloyd Weber musical or Hambone?
Hmm.
You got to end here thing the, the
Andrew Lloyd Weber musical. It's ours.
It's not just one hour. It's like two
and a half, I'm guessing. Two and a half,
three hours, right. Um, yeah.
To watch a musical or
you got to watch an hour.
I about Pam. Whoa. I would take it now.
I would take the Andrew Lloyd Webber.
I don't want to see a three hour anything.
I don't want to see three
hours of like the best standup.
I don't want to see a three hour
movie, three hour. I knew that.
I really hate going to something
that long. It's too, it's too much.
It's too much to too much, too much. Um,
this,
I
know also you'll enjoy this on
the way out of the show here.
We got to wrap up here soon. We got
to go to that meeting soon. Yup. Yup.
This point,
the information that we have is that
there is a male subject who has dedicated
his intoxication level
spewing poop all over the house.
What should I buy?
Carry here? What's going on, Gary?
She thinks I'm too drunk
to grab home. Okay. And uh,
I don't think I am, but,
okay. Let me ask you this.
Have you used the bathroom on
yourself? Well, yes. Okay, cool.
My main thing is this point,
I just want to make sure you don't
have any pcs on you anywhere. Oh,
I cleaned myself up in the bathroom.
Okay.
So I'm done when I have gas. Right.
It's a little bit more I got you.
But is it a crime to shit on oneself?
Well, let's, let's see what happened.
Hang tight right here for me for just a
second. Okay, let me go talk to Mindy.
Okay.
He said he cleaned himself up in here.
How much he's done twice. Oh
Wow. Yeah, I know. Seriously.
I don't mind him. Right. Okay.
Look at the front of the,
is this a crime for somebody to miss the
toilet subreddit and residents that we
didn't miss it? Look, there's
strict streaming down the
are some of my all over my walls.
Yeah.
And I need boots poopy underwater
today. My kitchen. I'm like,
what is wrong with a
little bit disgusting? Yes.
How will you might want
grab your dog? Hey, nasty.
I don't want the dog to get,
but is this, isn't this just like
a domestic issue? Sounds like it,
but also it sounds like she's helped.
Like she's like, will you talk to him?
I don't think they're like,
we're going to arrest him.
She's a good friend of mine. The lady and
I went to a bar and going further apart.
Yeah.
She's pretty picky about Cleveland
does. Sure. Yeah. She sounds like
real uptight. Yeah, she's good.
Yeah. What's wrong with her?
Here's the deal. Um, this officer's going
to be nice enough to take your home.
Okay.
She's going to take you home or not try
to push her forward out or anything like
that. And this car or pay, I
don't want to let you do what?
Try not to fart out or do anything in the
car with you to make a mess in his car.
Okay.
I think I just had to tell someone,
don't fart in this guy's car.
Oh that police officer had
the tell a civilian like,
could you not push your farts cause
you shit when you fart usually. Yeah.
I got to get a paid leave. I was
in there. Don't open that bag
in my car. We're all live out here and
you can come back and get those pitches.
A marriage,
a bag up.
Poor police officers.
Did you imagine getting called
out for this fucking nonsense?
Some drunk guy shitting myself in case
he happens to try to push her forward out
on the pushes out a little bit more again,
they can get all over the seat.
They're blonde girl right there.
You're going to try and do everything
you can to stay on that the entire time
you were in this car.
Okay,
no shit. Yeah. God bless the police. I
mean those are good cops right there. No.
Are you serious? I'm being serious.
Yeah, those are nice ones. They're like,
are you kidding me? What a Gig? Give
this fucking asshole. Could you imagine?
I mean, look, I know the
police get a bad rap and stuff,
but the amount of just nonsense you
have to deal with on a daily basis.
I mean you and I deal with drunk
people all the tall the time. Yeah.
And you add alcohol to somebody who's
already got their wires loose a little bit
and it is just like kerosene on
the fire. I mean, like this guy,
I'm sure when he's sober he probably
doesn't do that as much, you know?
No alcohol killer drugs and
alcohol man. All right. Which song?
There's two songs in my folder.
You want to pick one?
What do we got a one's called piss
on me by Logan stake. One is called,
you're not an anomaly by made
this one by Chris Spence.
Helen sounds real smart. So let's go with
Piss on me. Okay. Piss on me. Here it is.
We'll play the other ones the next one.
Next week. Yeah. Um, thanks for listening.
We've got to run. We've got to go
to this thing. I'll try it out.
We've got to try it out. Love you
guys. Thanks for listening. Bye Jane.
Two three.
Gotcha.
Hey,
Sierra high,
three nine
you can do to God
a lot, man. Gary Ryan, free food,
free rent and everything,
man. Here's the deal, man. Well, man,
is the deal man.
Med from jail home where sir,
come move and
then to free or at the said to me,
be me
all night.
You wanna see me. Come over
to you today. Try it out.
Try it out, man. If in my bills.
Oh, Chai, fucking piss off.
Siri. Siri. Fla Is,
I'm the a as fuck man.
I'm looking for hardcore guys.
I wanted to live or,
uh, I'm a, uh, game.
Why trashcan? Um, uh,
I'm a high fucking why trashcan.
But uh,
okay.